Florentine, ja die Profis sind hier, sagte Stefan Tietze, ja die Profis sind hier, einem neuen Podcast-UFO, Est 2014.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wir freuen uns sehr, dass wir euch begrüssen dürfen.
Wir sind schon lange auf dem Highway des Podcasts unterwegs. Wir lassen den Motor an.
Aber recht, ganz langsam rechts auf der Seite.
Ganz rechts Fahrgebot gilt.
Alle überholen uns, links und auch auf dem Seitenstreifen. Ja, das stimmt. Wo kein Gehweg ist, da gehe ich links, denn da kommen mir die Autos gelegen. Dieser Merksatz habe ich letztens wirklich mal, ich musste auf eine Strasse gehen ohne Rand und ohne Geländer. Ohne Rand und ohne Verstand. Ohne Verstand. Normalerweise halte ich mich ja am Geländer fest, wenn ich eine Strasse entlang gehe, aber war nicht möglich. Und dann habe ich überlegt, wie ging das Lied nochmal? Wo kein Gehweg ist, da gehe ich rechts. Ja, das ist das Dümmste. Beide einsilbig, einsilbig, kein Reim, keine Hilfe dieser Song in dem Moment, Herr Zukowski. Mal an der Stelle, wenn du Kindern helfen willst, dann komponier vielleicht Lieder mit einem Reinen. In der Weihnachtsbäckerei gibt es manche, wir wissen es nicht mehr, Schweinerei, Sauerrein, Kleckerei, es reint sich alles. Wo ist es? Das ist wichtig, wir haben es schon oft an Sprichwörtern kritisiert, an so Merkwörtern, Eselsbrücken, sie müssen sich auf das wichtige Wort reimen. Deswegen, was sehr gut funktioniert, ist, Bier auf Wein, das lass sein, Wein auf Bier, das rate ich dir. Weil das rate ich dir, das dir ist unmittelbar verknüpft mit dem Bier, das rate ich dir. Ach, das Bier muss ja zweites sein. Deswegen muss hinten stehen. Wein auf Bier, das rate ich dir. So, dann bin ich also die Strasse entlanggegangen, ja, kein Geländer in sich. Ach, ich habe so gehofft, dass du vergessen hast, dass ich vor so.
Und dann dachte ich, wo kann ich die Weg ist, da gehe ich links, da kommen mir die Autos entgegen, aber vor mir Rentner gehen rechts.
Also da dachte ich mir, wenn ich jetzt richtig gehe, links, dann gebe ich den Autos ja natürlich die Schlängeloptionen, man muss sowohl mich nicht umfahren als auch die Rentner, also habe ich zähneknirschend gesagt, gut, entgegen des Liedes gehe ich trotzdem rechts hin, den Rentner. Oder das ist ein politischer Song. Das kann natürlich immer sein, ne, das weiss man nicht. Da kommen mir die Panzer entgegen. Das kann gut sein. Wo kein Gehweg ist, da gehe ich links. Als Kind hat man das ja nicht verstanden, ne, Blau, blau, blau, blüht der Enzian, hatten wir damals noch harmloses Heimatlied. So blüht ja, weil das sind blaue Blumen, ja. Und mittlerweile kriegst du den Rechtsruck ins Gesicht, ne? Also das ist ganz knallhart. So, wir haben Nachricht bekommen von Micky, der meinte, ich esse gern Eis im Sommer. Finde ich klasse. Finde ich gut, ich bin richtig gut. Nee, ich bin ein bisschen nervös. Nee, ihr müsst auch nicht alles schreiben, nur weil E-Mails kostenlos sind. Also sie kosten schon, aber nicht euch was. Irgendwo auf der Welt wird jemand zur Kasse gebeten für eure Mail. Nicht ihr, aber irgendjemand muss blechen. Wer muss blechen? Netscape! Fucking Netscape muss zahlen! Was ich mich immer frage ist, warum ist ZGPT und diese ganzen KI-Software, warum sind die alle so günstig? Weil die verbraten doch einen Haufen Energie. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da nicht drin, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe nur letztes Mal ein witziges Video gesucht, wo jemand in der KI ein Bild gegeben hat.
Man meinte, gib mir das Exil. Ich bin da nicht drin, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe nur letztens... Oder es wird diese krassen... Okay. Wir haben jetzt das Video gesucht, wo jemand in der KI ein Bild gegeben hat.
Man meinte, gib mir das exakt gleiche Bild nochmal, bitte.
Ja.
Und dann haben das Bild...
Also die KI sollte das Bild exakt reproduzieren.
Hat auch ziemlich gut geklappt, aber Details sind halt immer anders.
Und dann haben die wieder das Bild der KI gegeben, das rausgekommen,
und haben gesagt, gib mir das gleiche.
Und haben das hunderte Mal gemacht und haben daraus dann ein Video gemacht, wie dieses Bild sich langsam verändert. Und es war halt so eine Frau, wo der Kopf immer so ein bisschen runtergegangen ist. Und irgendwann kamen dann so Arme dazu, wo sie den Kopf so aufgelegt hat, aber der Kopf wollte immer noch weiter nach unten. Und es ging so durch die Hände durch. Stell dir vor, sie wird so langsam zum Computer, der dir so zuguckt. Ja. So, was hast du vorher-mässig? Genau. Das ist ja gruselig. Das ist so lustig. Und wie du auch teilweise Leute hast, die dann so langsam zu einer Comicfigur werden und langsam hinter denen so Text auftaucht, so schlagartig irgendwie, dann irgendwie so Department of Security irgendwie so. Wo kommt das hier? Einfach so aus dem Nichts? Ganz lustig habe ich laut, laut, laut gelacht. Über die Konsequenzen meines Lachens habe ich mir in dem Moment keine Gedanken gemacht. Mal wieder keine Gedanken gemacht. Ja spannend, also was da passiert, ne? Holy Shit, da entwickelt sich gerade ganz viel. Oh, wir haben eine Mail bekommen von Marina. Im Sommer ist es mir oft zu heiß. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein Problem. Im Sommer ist es oft heiss, mir ist es auch dann zu heiss. Deswegen kann ich euch jetzt empfehlen, ich habe, das habe ich wirklich mal Game Changer, finde ich, gemerkt, ich brauche ja meine Bettdecke da nicht, aber man will auch nicht keine Decke haben. Genau, du willst was, reinzukuscheln, um körperliche Nähe zu simulieren. Genau. Und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt für so Sommer-Tagesdecken entschieden. So ganz dünne Wolldecken, aber nicht Wolldecken, sondern so ein Stoff, ich vergesse mal, wie der heisst, Musselin, Mulettin. Aber die Menschheit hat vor langer, langer Zeit die Wärmedecke erfunden. Hat viele Menschenleben gekostet, diese Erfindung. Wirklich ganz oft hört man irgendwie. Die Wright Brothers sind beide auf dem Weg dahin gestorben. Ganz Leute, oft verbrennen, irgendwie kochen, werden gar in ihrer Heizdecke, die Nacht über wachen, auf sind, gar und Ende, gar aus. Und wo ich mir denke, stopp, die Idee ist gut, aber lass uns doch die Kühldecke entfinden.
Also aus der, also umfinden. Es gibt schon die Erfindung, aber die umfinden. Stellt euch vor, ihr könntet im Sommer, im heißesten Sommer, 40 Grad, knallt in einer Dachparterrwohnung und ihr könntet sagen, ich wickel mich jetzt in meine dicke Decke ein, die eine Kühldecke ist. Ich habe immer noch den vollen Flausch, alles drin, aber da sind Kühlaggregate drin, die euch kühlen und ihr könnt euch so richtig einwickeln. Einkuscheln in die Kühlaggregate. Ja, weil, ne, aber sind wir mal ehrlich, die Welt wird immer heisser und immer mehr wird Schlafen zum Problem werden, weil wenn es heiss ist, kannst du nicht schlafen. Also die Kühldecke ist doch wirklich eine praktikable Lösung. Ja, gibt's für Hunde. Warum denken wir als Menschheit immer zuerst an die Hunde, das verstehe ich nicht. Ja, vielleicht will ich dem Ball auch hinterherlaufen. Ja, vielleicht will ich auch einen Kratzbaum. Und ganz ehrlich, Leckerli klingt, ich habe es nie probiert, aber es klingt mega lecker. Ja, so ein Knochen, an dem du rumkauen kannst, warum bietet die niemand mir? Stefan Leckerli, Stefan Leckerli. Ja, Stefan hätte gerne ein Leckerli. Das ist eine geile Idee. So ein quietschendes Plastikstück, so ein Knochen, wo man quietscht. Wäre jetzt nicht Priorität, aber finde ich schon noch cool. Aber ich würde, also ein paar Stunden könnte ich mich damit schon. Erwachsen werden ist es einzusehen, dass man das Leben seines Hundes leben will.
Ja, völlig richtig.
Ich will seine fucking Kühldecke.
Vielleicht will man, kauft man sich auch nur einen Hund, damit man denkt, zumindest ist einer von uns glücklich.
Wenn ich schon nicht glücklich sein kann, dann zumindest du.
Ein grosser Teil davon ist diese Einfachheit dieser Hundexistenz, ist schon, glaube ich, ein grosser Bestandteil der Faszination.
Having said that, es gibt eine Kühldecke, die steckt man in die Steckdose oder auch nicht, weiss ich nicht, ich habe mir das nie genau angeschaut, aber sie wird schon irgendwie künftig nieren. Und dann legt er sich da drauf, weil dann ist es schön kühl. Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so geil, was du gerade beschrieben hast. Ich glaube, man will nicht die ganze Nacht gekühlt werden, weil das würde ja auch den Kreislauf antreißen. Das ist natürlich wohltemperiert. Also da ist ein Thermostat drin, da ist eine Dampfmaschine drin, da ist ein Dieselmotor drin in der Bettdecke, das ist klar, das schwingt immer mit, dass da wirklich ein komplettes Aggregat mit drin ist. Ich glaube, eine dünne Decke ist gar nicht so schlecht. Nee, du kannst hier nicht so richtig reinkuscheln in so eine dünne Decke.
Das ist wirklich wie so ein Film, der da drüber liegt. Willst du nicht haben?
Ein feiner Film, aber es ist so spannend, dass selbst der hilft einem ja auch schon,
dieses Deckengefühl zu haben.
Ja, ja, die Bettdecke ist ja viel mehr als eine Temperatur.
Es ist so dieses Schutz, Sicht, Schutz auch.
Das Messer des Mörders würde nicht aufgehalten werden von der Bettdecke.
Natürlich nicht, aber trotzdem. Aber du willst auch einfach deinen fetten, schwitzigen Körper nicht der Welt zur Schau stellen, auch wenn niemand im Raum ist, aber trotzdem schämst du dich. Nee, du bist Deepstreamer. Das ist richtig, das ist ein Punkt. Die Welt ist bei dir zu Hause. Ja, das stimmt, die Leute schauen zu und da willst du natürlich nicht den schwitzigen, fetten Wahlkörper der Welt zur Schau setzen. Aber ich glaube, das wäre eine gute Erfindung, aber werden wahrscheinlich auch wieder einige Leute zum Opfer fallen. Müssen für gute technologische Entwicklungen nicht auch einfach ein paar Menschen sterben? Selbstverständlich, ja. Und damit stehen wir für unseren Namen. Podcast. Ihr werdet alle sterben, aber zumindest einen sinnvollen Tod. Ich bin noch gar nicht bei KI angekommen. Ich hole noch Technologie nach. Ich bin ein bisschen nervös, denn ich werde nach der Podcast-Folge Aufzeichnungen ein Paket abgeben. Und ich mache das ganz, ganz selten, mal was zu verschicken. Und heute ist es aber soweit. Ich habe ein Paket gepackt für einen Freund von mir, dem ich was schicke. Und ich bin wirklich ein bisschen aufgeregt. Was ist da drin? Da sind Magic-Karten drin. Ich habe Magic-Karten bekommen als Promomaterial, die aber nie gebraucht, da ich Magic online spiele. Ich habe ja schon mal gesagt, Magic erzählt die besten Geschichten, und das ist eine. Diese Geschichte jetzt mit dem Paket? Ja, genau. Okay. Es könnte auch alles andere in diesem Paket sein. Nee. Ich finde die Magic-Aspekte bislang den langweiligsten Aspekt an der Geschichte. Magic erzählt die besten Geschichten. Ich finde dein Leben … Frag mich noch mal nach der Geschichte. Und ich habe die immer bekommen, aber ich konnte damit nichts anfangen, weil ich immer nur Online-Magic gespielt habe. Also hatte ich diese Karten … Aber Moment, hast du dich trotzdem so werbewirksam in die Kamera gehalten und allen gesagt, so kauf das, kauf das, kauf das, das ich einfach bekommen von der Firma? Das Problem ist, die Marketingabteilung ist streng getrennt, in digital und handfest. Und die Handfestabteilung, die kann ja nicht, also es gibt keine Überschneidung, die sagen, ah cool, du machst Magic Streams, wir schicken dir Promo. Wir haben aber keinen Einfluss auf den digitalen Teil unseres Produkts. Jetzt würde ich sagen, aber es ist wie so Kampf gegen Fire and Ice. Also im Idealfall hat dann die analoge Marketingpferdung immer noch mehr Macht. Sie kann den digitalen Leuten die Stecker ziehen. Könnte es sich tun, ja. Das kann man aber auch sagen, wenn man denen die Stecker zieht, ja, wir haben alles in der Cloud, wohingegen die analogen, denen kann man ja die Karten verbrennen, haben die gar nichts mehr. Richtig. Na gut, wir haben vielleicht noch eine Kopie irgendwo rumliegen. Aber es ist ein harter Kampf. Auf jeden Fall habe ich ganz viele Magic-Karten. Ich habe herausgefunden, dass ein Kumpel von mir jetzt Magic spielt und ganz viele Karten braucht. Mir ist es nicht gefallen. Nee, dich habe ich nicht gefragt, weil du dich immer über meine Magic-Anekdoten lustig machst. Dann sagst du überhaupt nicht. Magic ist zu langweilig, weil ich immer sage, Magic erzählt die besten Geschichten, und du sagst, nein, Magic erzählt die langweiligsten Geschichten. Das habe ich noch nie gesagt. Doch, das hast du nach einer Aufzeichnung, als die Mikrofone bereits sich die Uhren zugehalten und la la la gesagt haben, hast du gesagt, Florentin, ich will dir einmal mal sagen, Magic erzählt die langweiligsten Geschichten. Das war nur eine Retourkutsche darauf, weil du mir mal nach einer Aufzeichnung gesagt hast, wenn du noch einmal anfängst, von Peru zu erzählen, beende ich dieses Projekt. Und hat es geklappt? Na, guck mal. So, und jetzt muss ich diese Magic-Karten verschicken und ich habe keine Erfahrung im Paketpacken. Also du brauchst ja beim, ein gutes Paket hat ja auch so Füllermaterial, ne, so diese, diese... Ich bin gerade, ich bin gerade, ich verkaufe gerade alles. Ja? Ich verkaufe gerade alle Klamotten. Ja. Ich verkaufe gerade, ich laufe jeden Tag dutzend Male zu jeglichem Versandunternehmen. Es gibt sehr viele Versandunternehmen. Ich verstehe, dass dich das überhaupt nicht packt, weil du regelmäßig packst und regelmäßig Ich fühle mich gerade wie so ein Einzelhändler. Genau, und ich habe das nie. Für mich ist das eine absolute neue Erfahrung und deswegen habe ich auch nicht das Material dafür. Und es gibt ja dieses merkwürdige Material.
Zeitungen. Genau, ich habe keine Zeitung im Haus. Hallo, als ob ich Zeitung lesen würde, wie so ein Eierkopf oder was. Nee, und deswegen habe ich so ein Zeug nicht im Hause. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, dieses merkwürdige, es gibt so Dinge, die sind nutzlos, aber man braucht sie, weil sie nutzlos sind, so wie dieses Füllmaterial.
Das darf nichts Nützliches sein, weil man sonst für was anderes benutzen würde.
Ich komme auch oft mit meinem Minimalist-Lifestyle auf meine Grenzen, bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, weil ich hasse Kram, ich hasse alles, was so entferntesten zuletzt vor sechs Monaten angefasst wurde, überlege ich ernsthaft zu verschenken, zu verkaufen oder wegzuwerfen. Und deswegen, dann hat man aber sowas nicht im Haus, wie zum Beispiel Zeitschriften oder sowas, die man dafür gebrauchen kann, um Pakete zu stopfen. Genau, ja, habe ich nicht. Und dann musste ich das Paket stopfen, alles, was ich hatte, sind leere Klopapierrollen. Ich gehe mal an den Müll der Nachbarn ran. Okay. Für alte Filme, also für andere. Und dann kommt bei irgendjemandem an mit irgendwelchen Rechnungen und Mahnungen von anderen Leuten und die fragen, Stefan, alles okay bei dir? Manchmal bin ich abgelenkt durch spannend aussehende Briefe, ja. Und ich hatte nichts ausser leere Klopapierrollen, die ich nicht wegschmeisse. Und dann überlegt man natürlich, wie viele Klopapierrollen muss man in das Paket legen, damit es als Füllmaterial verstanden ist. Und will man sofort Assoziationen wecken in Richtung, weil Klopapieren sind ja gemeinhin das nächste an deinem Stuhlgang. Genau. Und warum muss man das dann? Und man denkt sich, wow, der verbraucht ganz schön viel Klopapier, weil er kann letzten Endes, es waren vier Klopapierrollen. Was nicht so viel ist, aber in der Masse das zu sehen, suggeriert, boah, der verbraucht aber viel. Und ich dachte mir, aber vier ist nicht genug, weil ich glaube, mein Freund macht das Paket auf und denkt sich, warum schickt er mir vier leere Klopapierrollen? Wir sind noch nicht bei der Menge, wo man merkt, ah, das ist nutzloses Füllmaterial, weil wenn da 30 drin wären, ah, okay, das Füllmaterial, aber vier hatte ich das Gefühl, das ist noch nicht dieser Sweet-Spot-Idee, Game-Changing-Idee, weil dieses Füllmaterial, finde ich, ist oft eine Verschwendung, weil oft habe ich da so Raspeln drin von so alten Kartons oder sowas, die dann weggeschmissen werden.
Ja, genau.
Dann sind sie weg.
Ja.
Wie wäre es denn, wenn man als bei jeder Firma muss man anklicken können, was man als Füllmaterial nutzen will Und es ist immer was Sinnvolles, wie zum Beispiel voller Klopapierrollen. Ah, okay. Oder volle Küchenpapierrollen. Oder einfach Dinge, die auch stossdämpfend wirken und füllend, aber eben auch, die man eh immer mal braucht. Und dann musst du anklicken und die zahlst du dann auch. Ja, ja, genau. Geile Idee eigentlich. Also so Küchenrollen oder Backpapier oder sowas, was einfach immer dabei ist. Halt irgendwie so Dinge, die man eh immer braucht. Reis. Ja, ich denke, ich denke mir so, Reis ist ein Superfüllmaterial. Mehl. Ich denke mir so. Ach, Mehlbrand. Ich denke mir. Ah, Mehlexplosion. Ich finde diese Schaum … Wie sagt man Styroporbohnen? Styropor ist doch einfach eine Pest. Ja, die so als Füllmaterial dabei sind. Die kennst du diese … Du kriegst nichts von mir. Aber habe ich das geträumt oder existiert? Das ist wirklich diese Schaumstoff … Die so aussehen wie so dicke Erdnussflips. Genau, die werden ja extra dafür produziert, sinnlos, einfach Füller zu sagen. Gut, jetzt sagst du das den Styroporwerken in Brauweiger. Kamandu. Kamandu. Aber ich denke mir manchmal, kann man stolz zur Arbeit gehen, wenn du in der Fabrik arbeitest, die diese Dinge herstellt, die ja produziert werden, um nutzlos zu sein. Ähnlich wie wenn du Mülltüten herstellst. Du stellst ein Produkt her … Ja, da ist noch Innovation drin, erstens. Reisfest können die ein bisschen besser reisfest sein. Okay, sag mal neun weitere Merkmale einer guten Mülltüte? Dann, dass man die nicht immer nachfilmen muss, also irgendwie was Cooles, dass man die nicht so auf, dass man die einfacher aufmachen kann, einfach zumachen kann. Ich meine, da ist man schon recht weit mit diesem Band oben drin. Mit dem Marktführer echt und direkt. Ja, aber da wurden auch schon Leute gelacht darüber, die gesagt haben, da gab es nämlich, damals gab es auch jemanden, der gesagt hat, die kann noch besser werden, Leute haben gelacht, wie du jetzt. Und dann hat er dieses typisches Band erfunden, was man dann so zuziehen kann. Und dann hat niemand mehr gelacht.
Niemand mehr gelacht. Aber ist dieses Füllmaterial, ich denke gerade, weil so eine Firma, die die Sachen verkauft, die hat ja auch Müll. Ist es einfach eine Möglichkeit für Firmen, den Müll billig zu verschicken? Es ist wie ein schlechtes Weihnachtsgeschenk, was immer weiter geschenkt wird. Ja, angenommen, du bestellst eine Lampe und die haben ja Müll in der Firma und die sagen, schredde einfach den Müll und stopfe das als Füllmaterial in die Lampe, weil der Kunde muss es dann wegwerfen. Ich kann nicht verstehen, warum Leute diese Schaumstoffbohnen, die ärgern mich, weil man kann einfach irgendwas anderes nehmen, als extra herzustellen. Ja, neulich habe ich wirklich so ganz kleine Sachen bestellt und dann kam es ein grosser Karton an und da drin waren einfach diese Luftpolstertaschen, also so aufgepumpte, grosse Luftkissen in Plastik. Und dann sitzt man da zu Hause und macht die kaputt und schmeißt die weg. Und dann ist das Plastikmüll, der da, aber das ist nicht irgendwie zweckentfremdet oder sowas, sondern es ist nur dafür da. Und so wie es aussieht, wurde es auch noch nie verwendet. Vor allem, die werden ja nicht da hergestellt, wo das verpackt wird. Hoffentlich nicht. Also sagen wir mal, du verkaufst Schuhe und sagst, fuck, wir brauchen Füllmaterial. Wir kaufen jetzt diese... Und so wurde aus Geox dann eine Füllmaterialfirma. Genau, aber da kommt ein Laster an und in dem Laster sind Kartons, in denen nur diese Plastikschläuche drin sind.
Ja.
Sind die schon aufgeblasen? Und dann lädt jemand diese Kartons mit den Schläuchen ab und lädt die wieder da rein.
Also das ist ja eine komplette Lieferkette von Füllmaterial.
Ist da auch wieder Füllmaterial drin für diese Plastikschläuche, damit die gut verschifft werden können? Oder sind die wiederum Füllmaterial bei anderen Dingen, also angenommen, du hast eine Schuhfirma und du bestellst deine Rohstoffe, um die Schuhe herzustellen, du brauchst aber auch diese Fülldinger, bestellst du die Fülldinger separat oder sagst du, Moment mal, pass mal auf. Die sind Teil meines Businesses. Oder du sagst angenommen, du bestellst Gummi und sagst, ey, könnt ihr das Gummi bitte mit diesen Füllern versehen und dann nimmst du die Füller wieder für deine eigenen Produkte. Also die Frage ist, wo fängt die an? Ich glaube, es ist immer Müll. Ich brauche ja für meine Schuhproduktionen habe ich ganz viele Müll.
Ich bestelle ganz viel Gummi. Und das Gummi kommt auch mit Füllmaterial. Also entweder A, in Wirklichkeit A, du bist eine Firma, die bei der Produktion Dinge bestellt, die mit Füllmaterial kommen. Genau, und du gibst das Füllmaterial einfach weiter. Ja, oder du bist eine Firma, die einfach von sich aus produziert, dabei entsteht aber Müll, was du als Füllmaterial benutzen kannst. Das sind jetzt zwei. Möglichkeit drei ist, du produzierst etwas und du hast kein Füllmaterial, brauchst aber auch keins. Möglichkeit vier ist, du produzierst etwas, hast kein Füllmaterial, es entsteht auch nichts, du brauchst aber was. Genau. Wo kriegen die das her? Und das ist die Frage, weil deine Frage ist ja, gibt es Firmen, die nur das herstellen? Die nur diese Plastikschläuche mit Luft verkaufen, die dann einschiffen. Die ist frisch. Ich habe das Gefühl, weil diese noch so prall sind. Und so dicht ist dieses Plastik nicht. Weißt du, ich meine, man legt das eine Woche lang hin, dann geht das so ein. Das gibt mir das Gefühl, dass diese Elektronikfirma, wo ich diese zwei Nocken gekauft habe, die hat das aufgefüllt. Die verkauft aber Elektronik-Einzelteile. Aber werden die verkauft aufgeblasen oder muss die Schuhfirma dann auch so einen Kompressor in der Halle stehen haben, wo einer dann die immer aufpumpt?
Das meine ich. Die Elektrofirma hat das aufgeblasen. Die Luft kommt von denen. Wir werden irgendwie zu so einem Logistik-Podcast. Letzte Woche über Restposten, jetzt geht es nochmal um Füller. Aber es ist spannend, Logistik ist es einfach. Geht es nicht gerade da draußen in der Welt, genau darum. Wegen Schamszöllen.
Und wahrscheinlich, du hast einigen Mal einen extra drei Beitrag gesehen und seitdem wirklich immer. Vor allem, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn am Ende es heisst, okay, Gesamtwirtschaft der Erde, wie viel Geld wird mit Lebensmitteln verdient, wie viel Geld mit Schuhen verdient. Und auf Nummer eins ist Füllmaterial. Das ist die grösste Industrie der gesamten Welt, weil alle Füllmaterial brauchen.
Und da verdient sich irgendjemand eine goldene Nase, irgendwo aus Lützenich oder irgendein so ein kleines Dorf, wo jemand sagt, ich produziere das gesamte Schüllmaterial. Ob diese Preise haben und der Preis. Ja, für das beste Füllmaterial. Für den besten, nee, nee, aber nee, krasse Unterkategorien.
Ja.
Für das beste Luft-induced Füllmaterial geht dieses Jahr. An Werner Brankhorst aus Bremen, fuck, für seine neue Innovation, Luft in noch kleinere Fülltaschen zu packen. Ja, also kann man, es kann jeder auf seinen auch wenn du filmst. Die Antwort ist nein, aber also so mit Anlauf. Da läuft jemand, man sieht den stundenlang auf die Kamera zu laufen, nein rufen und dann läuft der weg. Also wenn du so Filmmaterial stellst, ist es wirklich das Lebensbusiness, die Traditionsfirma? Hat, also hat, es gibt es in jeder Branche. Ja, ich habe mir heute gedacht, also lieben Gruss an meine Familie, die hatten vor einigen Wochen ein hundertjähriges Firmenjubiläum. Glückwunsch, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Wird mit dir die Familientradition sterben oder wirst du es nicht? Nein, nein, nein, mein Cousin ist ja zu einem. Ach, das ist gut. Also die Seite der Familie ist gesichert, es gibt einen Stammhalter, ein Stammhalter wurde gebahrt, aufgebaut. Bist du die Enttäuschung der Familie, weil du es nicht übernimmst? Nee, das war, tatsächlich war ich nie in der Position, das entscheiden zu müssen, Gott sei Dank. Aber es läuft also weiter und es geht der Firma gut und jetzt 100 Jahre fand ich ziemlich krass und dann gab es eine Firmenfeier, alle waren mega stolz und es war super schön, weil ja, finde ich, auch so jetzt Klimatechnik und Haustechnik ist einfach ein wichtiger Aspekt, kann man darauf stolz sein. Ja, und da bin ich heute an so einem Toupet-Laden vorbeigekommen. Da stand so, das war auch so ein Familienbetrieb, da war so gross, so ein Logo drauf und dann stand da ganz gross Toupets.
Da dachte ich mir so, was war auch so ein Familienbetrieb, da war so gross so ein Logo drauf und dann stand da ganz gross Toupets.
Da dachte ich mir so, was wenn die hundert Jahre haben? Und dann feiern die das genauso stolz und gross, dass es Toupets gibt, weil im Prinzip ist ja Eitelkeit, also nicht dieses, dieser normale, dieser normale Bedarf an funktionierenden Sanitäreinrichtungen, ein funktionierendes Klo, Badarmaturen, halt du willst keinen fucking Wasserschaden in der Wohnung haben oder eine Klimaanlage, all das ist ja ein Grundbedarf. Toupets ist ja aus einem komischen Gefühl von Eitelkeit, was man immer kritisieren kann, auch. Auch aus einer Mode heraus, kann ja sein, dass Glatzen irgendwann super in sind oder so. Ja, aber anders als Modefirma zum Beispiel braucht man ja keine Toupets, aber du musst ja was anzuziehen haben. Ja, ja, okay. Aber es ist so komisch, weil ich dachte mir wirklich, was wenn die Hundertjähriges haben und kommt denn da auch die Familie und feiert mit und gibt es da auch auch so ein Pommes-Auto und so eine Grafik-Type?
Wahrscheinlich schon. Also ich glaube, es gibt schon Leute, die nicht stolz sein können, angenommen, du programmierst Pop-Ups für Pornoseiten, wo dir irgendwie so Betrugsfrauen aus deiner Nähe wollen dich kennenlernen, so ein Zeug. Ich weiss nicht, ob man da wirklich sagt Familie Sünner. Das ist Sünners Pop-Up-Store.
Seit hundert Jahren Sünners Pop-Up-Stps. Wir programmieren handgemachte Pop-Ups, wo wirklich also Betrug noch aus erster Hand, wo wirklich die IP-Adresse ausgelesen wird mit wirklich guten, guten Programmen. Ja, das ist ein Meisterbetrieb. Meisterbetrieb Sünner Pop-Ups. Da hat der Fred uns was programmiert für die IP-Adressenauslesung. Dippelink. genau damit wir sehen, wo du wohnst und dann werden dir heisse Frauen aus der Nachbarschaft angezeigt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die stolz darauf sind, auf das, was sie machen. Aber vielleicht schon.
Ich meine, das Internet gibt es auch lang genug, dass es gewisse Traditionen gibt.
Ich finde, Toupets ist schon nicht mehr, das Hundertjährige wird nicht mehr gross gefeiert. Es sei denn, du hast es wirklich zu Franchising-mäßig, so ein Riesending. Aber das ist ja ein kleiner Laden, der da steht.
Ich glaube schon, wenn Leute sagen, danke für dein Toupe, dass du dich ein gutes Toupe hat. Ich glaube auch, dass es sinnvoll ist für viele Leute. Ich finde es nur so, es ist so, vielleicht ist es auch zu kurz gedacht.
Ja, absolut. Ich glaube, als jemand, der den Beruf aus ist so, vielleicht ist es auch zu kurz gedacht.
Ja, absolut. Ich glaube, als jemand, der den Beruf ausfüllt, siehst du wahrscheinlich auch anders, wie dieser Beruf die Welt beeinflusst. Wir denken uns, keine Ahnung, so was wäre Schönheits-OP oder so, denkt man sich, okay, eigentlich eine Branche, die in der perfekten Welt nicht existieren müsste, wenn alle Menschen mit ihrem Körper zufrieden wären und so bla bla bla bla. Aber wenn du in dem Job arbeitest, siehst du vielleicht, okay, ich kann damit Menschen glücklich machen oder irgendwie, denen geht es gut oder sowas in der Richtung. Und dann hast du wahrscheinlich ein anderes Bild. Ich glaube, der Anreiz ist ein anderer, schöner als zurückzuwerden, aber... Weiss man nicht, weiss man nicht. Vielleicht, also ich meine, es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche Aten und Schulheitsoperationen, aber so jetzt klassische, irgendwie so die klassischen oberflächlichen Sachen. Genau, da bin ich schon klar, da ist ein Anreiz.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob die, also denkst du die, haha, zum Glück haben wir Geld, wir sind Betrüger, wir sind die Lüge der Gesellschaft, wir nutzen das niedrige Selbstbewusstsein von Menschen aus?
Glaube ich nicht, dass die so ihr Leben denken.
Natürlich nicht.
Oh, aber du denkst, die sind dann böse oder was?
Nee, ich glaube, Menschen sind sehr gut im Rationalisieren. Aber von aus, ja, okay. Es arbeiten noch ganz viele Leute stolz bei Rheinmetall und sagen, wir machen hier was Gutes. Ja, okay, aber das kann ich ja irgendwie für Argumentieren. Also ich glaube schon, wie gesagt, das ist ein Punkt. Rheinmetall verstehe ich schon auch noch, dass man sich das irgendwie hininterpretieren kann. Aber wenn du jetzt wirklich so Betrugs-Pop-Ups machst. Ach so, ja, ja, ja. Es gibt, glaube ich, schon einen Punkt, wo du dir das nicht mehr hinteregst.
Wo du denkst, okay, ich bin vielleicht einfach ein schlechter Mensch, aber keine Ahnung, ich brauche halt Geld und das ist mein Ding und damit kann man gut Geld und die Vollidioten, die drauf reinfallen, irgendwie nur die Dummen fallen drauf rein oder so. Ich glaube, argumentierst du jetzt schon irgendwo hin? Aber wenn man aus den Strafländern zuhört, teilweise beim Erklären ihrer Straftaten und so, wie sie sich dabei gefühlt haben und so.
Und manchmal spielt da auch nicht so viel Reue mit, sondern ist so ein bisschen so, ja, wo die Dummheit, ja, ja, genau, ja, dann hätte ich es nicht gemacht, hätte ein anderer gemacht. Ja.
Also jetzt mal ein Beispiel von How to Sell, Drugs Online Fast, der hat der Originaltyp, hat ja auch nie gesagt, das war ja grösste Fehler meines Lebens oder so, sondern er hat gesagt, ja, wenigstens habe ich es verkauft, aber ich habe wenigstens gutes Ecstasy verkauft. Ja, ja, ja. Also selbst gar gekriegend der Mensch ist ein fucking Rationalisierungsmonster und der kriegt das hin, weil du kommst nicht damit klar, dein Leben lang und auch noch, wenn du ein berühmter wirst mit sowas, kommst du aber nicht damit klar, dass das alles auf einem Fakt aufbaut, dass du ein betrügerisches Arschloch bist. Menschen kriegen es immerhin, sich recht zu fertigen, weil auch, glaube ich, wenn du acht Stunden am Tag in in einer Firma arbeitest, egal was die macht, am Ende musst du darauf stolz sein, weil sonst nimmst du dein Leben als … Also es gibt immer eine Identifikation mit einer Firma. Das stimmt, ja. Ich fand so krass, weil ich will immer, meine Mutter hat ja immer die Pumpen und Steigrohre hergestellt für Haarspray und Seifen und so, also die Pumpen, Pumpsysteme. Ja. Und das war ja mega geil. Und ich, auch diese paar Wochen, wo ich dann immer da gearbeitet habe, so in Ferien, die Identifikation, die du sehr schnell mit diesem sehr, sehr speziellen Gegenstand hast, ist immens. Ja, stimmt, irgendwann fällt dir das auf, so bei der Deus, ah, das ist jetzt kein guter Pump. Nee, aber die haben ja auch Bilder dann da hängen von Sprühpumpen. Ja, also die. Du meinst sowas so, so, so Deosprays, sowas. Alles, also alles, wo man draufdrückt und es kommt was raus. Hans-Einser, Hans-Einser. Dispenster, genau, das sind Lotion-Pumpen, klassische Lotion-Pumpen, das sind dickflüssigere Sachen, die man natürlich rausbezogen, mit einem dickeren Steigrohr und dann hast du oben … Auch so Schlagsahnedosen und so Sprühdosen? Ja, klar. Also da ist so früher noch dieses Treibgas drin, das ist wohl irgendwann verboten. Ja. Wie hieß es nochmal? UCDC. Ja, sowas. Und das gibt ja auch andere Sachen. Ja. Sage ich wahrscheinlich irgendwelche verbotenen Sachen oder so. Ja, genau. UCKW. Ja, ja, ja. UCKW, UCKW, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
Begritzung, ja.
Jedenfalls, ich meine nur, da fehlt dann irgendwann den All-Mitarbeitern, auch finde ich zu Recht, die können ja auch noch stolz darauf sein, weil es etwas ist, was man braucht und was cool ist, aber der Identifikationsgrad, den die dann mithaben, mit diesem Ding, die sind halt crazy, das ist halt deren Leben. Und ich fand das immer schön zu beobachten und auf eine gewisse Art brauchst du das wahrscheinlich auch, um so viel Leben da zu verbringen. Aber ich frage mich, ob die dann anders sprühen, ob die dann wirklich selber sich ein Deo kaufen und sagen, ah, okay, da ist ein bisschen drück, ist ein bisschen fester oder so, ist das einer von uns? Ah, nee, ist keiner von uns, ne, ist ein minderwertiges Druck-Pump-Sprüh-Ding. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob man dann anders durch die Welt, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Aber es stimmt schon, die Identifikation mit einer Firma ist, ich schaue manchmal so Videos von jemandem im Internet, der so indische Betrugs-Callcenter dann so infiltriert, hops nimmt und so und da sich in dieeras hackt und so. Und das sind halt so Betrugsmaschen, so ja, ich bin von Microsoft, ihr, ihr, ihr, ihr, ein Virus, bitte rufen Sie an, damit wir den Virus so und dann müssen die ja Kreditkartennummer und so. Und der, der kann da halt sich mit Viren wiederum in deren Systeme hacken und so und kann dann sehen, was die machen und so was. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, das ist halt so ein Grossraumbüro, wo die halt teilweise auch lachen und so und mit Kaffeetassen da halt rumstehen. Und wenn dann irgendwie so eine Kunde kommt, dann kommen die auch alle zusammen und gucken dann wirklich so und so, was krass, der kennt da einen echten Namen und so, weil die stellen sich irgendwie falschen Namen vor und so was. Und dann kommen die auch zusammen und dann lachen die auch noch krass und so und die werden wahrscheinlich auch eine gute Zeit haben. Aber die kommen auch morgens müde zur Arbeit. Ja, aber das sind einfach Betrüger, die wissen, dass sie betrügen jeden Tag und die haben teilweise einfach Rentner am Telefon. Aber die haben ja auch einen Betriebsrat. Weiß nicht, ob die einen Urlaub zusammen haben oder Teambuilding-Massnahmen, dass die mal zusammen bowlen gehen oder so. So eine Betrugsfirma, dass die halt dann wirklich sagen. Gibt es eine SopranosFolge, wo die mal so zusammen irgendwie teambuilding, Escape Room? Ich weiss, ja, kann schon sein, aber das, vielleicht das auch. Aber irgendwann nimmt ja organisierte Kriminalität so ein Organisationsverwaltungsapparat auch mit sich auf, dass man dann da trotzdem steht, Ambassador Spender und du führst Orgobespräche über die Buchhaltung, weil was haben die wieder gemacht. Und dann geht die Kamera, zieht auf und dann ist es einfach eine Betrugsfirma. Aber man steht trotzdem mit so einer World's Best Boss Kaffeeltasse. Genau, ja, und du meinst, wir könnten ja trotzdem einen dritten Quartal. Das wäre schon schön, wenn wir eine andere Kaffeemaschine, weil ich mag die nicht. Und ich war neulich bei Drinks drüben und die hatten eine bessere. Ja, aber das Problem ist, wir haben ja jetzt irgendwie, die Marianne ist jetzt hier mit laktosefreier Milch. Und das heißt, wir brauchen eine Kaffeemaschine mit zwei Kammern für Milch. Laktosefreier Milch und normale Milch. Ja, meinetwegen zwei Kammern. Ja, aber das ist halt ein anderes... Oder sie schicken gleich mal kein Cappuccino, sondern einfach ein Kaffee au lait. Aber ja, aber ich bin ja auch Riesenfan von Kaffee au lait. Das Problem ist halt, dass dass du dann direkt im anderen Kreis... Ah, hi, worüber redet ihr denn? Auch. Mich etwa? Nein, nee, also es ging um die Kaffeemaschine im Konkreten, weil wir haben jetzt die neue mit den zwei Kammern. Aber nicht jetzt schon wieder, weil ich jetzt irgendwie die einzige bin, die... Nein, gar nicht. Wir finden es ja toll, wir finden es ja super, dass du da... Also habt ihr darüber gesprochen, also weil wir sind beide ganz doll rot, also... Wir haben, nein, wir haben, gut, wir haben jetzt heute auch einen harten Telefon-Tag gehabt oder so, wir mussten die Rentner anrufen und ihnen das Geld aus der Tasche ziehen und so. Ja, ich weiß, ich hatte auch keinen schönen, das ist auch für mich irgendwie ein anstrengender Tag gewesen. Ja, und das Problem ist halt, wenn die halt am Telefon weinen und sagen, ihr habt dann die Erspartes überwiesen und wir sind Betrüger und so, das ist halt auch, da muss man auch dann wieder in sich gehen und sagen, okay, wofür mache ich das eigentlich?
So, ne, und was ist eigentlich, oder, also denkt ihr nicht auch manchmal darüber nach, so, also, in dem Moment denke ich mir halt im Sinne von so.
Bislang eigentlich nicht, also ich glaube, also.
Ne, aber ich meine, was ist denn eigentlich das grosse ganze Ziel?
Ich meine, klar, wir machen Geld für Mr. Jakamoto, der am Ende abkassiert und so, und wir müssen halt das Leid und Elend jeden Tag ertragen. Ich meine, die sind ja auch selber dumm, oder? Die sind ja dumm, oder? Oder haben wir vielleicht so eine rassistische Note, dass wir sagen, die in ihrem reichen, tollen Land und haben zu viel sie ... Oder in welche Richtung gehen wir? Nee, also ... Na, ich meine halt ... Es ist so ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, dass wir darüber nicht sprechen. Okay, okay. Wie du dich beitragst, versuchen wir alle krampfhaft normale Bürogespräche zu führen, um nicht das Gefühl zu haben, dass wir vor allem Betrüger sind, okay? Hey, worum geht's ... Redet ihr auch über die kleinen Hanutas? Ja, genau. Ich denke so, ihr seid uns so klein. Ich meine, wir sind so einfach zu klein. Vor allem ist es ja nicht mal ein Viertel von einem normalen Hanuta. So, wenn wir uns kleine Hanutas, ja, kommen die durch. Normalität zu suggerieren. Ich glaube, das geht. Ich glaube auch, das geht. Im Endeffekt ist es alles nur Alltag. Wir versuchen ja gerade generell auch so ein bisschen die Problematiken, die da draußen herrschen, in den Servicebetrieben und den Serviceberufen da draußen so ein bisschen zu klären. Wir haben ein großes Thema mit Trinkgeld, da haben wir den grossen Trinkgeld-Boykott aufgerufen durch akzeleraristisch. Genau, wir haben uns einen Akzelerismus versucht. Interessant, ich dachte, da geht eine Welle durch Deutschland, gar nichts.
Ja, ja, warte mal, warte mal, es ist ein Slow Burner, es ist ein Slow Burner und dann passiert schon was. Slow Burner, würde ich sagen. Aber wir haben gerade so ein bisschen die Serviceberufe auf dem Kika, wir versuchen da ein bisschen was zu klären, wir haben Florentins Service-Ecke eingeführt, da gibt es ganz viele Bewerbungen für Leute. Genau, wir sind ja gerade noch in der Auswahlphase. Genau. Und ich finde es aber spannend, weil es geht darum, wir wollen herausfinden, was sind die, wie soll man sich, so eine Art Knigge eigentlich zu erstellen. Also wie sollen wir uns verhalten, was soll man machen, was geht euch auf die Nerven, was ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlimm und so. Einfach so, man will ja den Betriebsablauf nicht stören. Genau. Und wie kriegen wir das hin? Und da kam jetzt eine spannende Nachricht an uns erreicht über unsere Kontaktformular auf unserer Website. Dann gehen wir doch jetzt einfach mal in Florentin-Service-Ecke. Ecke, Ecke, Ecke, Ecke, Ecke. Heute bei uns in Florentin-Service-Ecke zu Gast Stefan Tietze. Hallo Stefan. Hi. Ja, ich falle ganz schön. Schön, dass du zu Gast bist. Was hast du mitgebracht? Ich bin nicht Gast, wir machen das schon ewig zusammen. Was hast du uns mitgebracht? Ja, also und zwar schreibt der liebe Matteo, weil wir haben ja noch nicht die Bewerbung, sie wird nicht durchgegangen, dass wir jetzt Ansprechpartner haben, aber wir haben eine nächste Frage und die finde ich super gut, haben wir auch schon aufgestellt und ich fand es gut. Es ist ein bisschen, wir machen ein bisschen die sogenannte Gegenwart-Gegenwartscheck jetzt mit der Service-Tecke. Ja genau und vor allem wir sind mittlerweile auch genauso faul wie die, dass wir keine Gegenwartschecks mehr selber machen, sondern nur noch die aus der Community nehmen. Reißt euch mal zusammen. Was macht ihr sonst, Ijoma und Nina und Lars? Frage für die Service-Ecke. Eine wichtige Frage für die Service-Ecke. Wissen, also wenn du das schon in Betreff schreibst, dann muss es ja nicht nur meine Nachricht, weil da geht einfach... So, das ist nämlich auch unsere Serviceeckel, um die Ecke, was wir euch auch Servicefeedback geben, wie man Mails und Kommentare schreiben sollte. Wissen KassiererInnen, dass viele Kopfhörer einen Transparenzmodus haben und ich sie gut verstehen kann und ich mit denen reden könnte oder denken die einfach, das ist unhöflich, nicht mehr die Kopfhörer rauszunehmen? Oder ist denen das einfach egal? Ich finde das eine super Frage. Liebe Grüße gehen nach Mannheim, lieber Matteo. Ich finde das genau ein sehr, sehr gut beobachteter Punkt, weil super oft bin ich mit Kopfhörern im Supermarkt. Ich finde Supermarkt auch sehr anstrengend. Ich schwitze, habe Angst die ganze Zeit. Ich habe Probleme im Supermarkt. Und deswegen habe ich gerne Musik auf den Orden und Podcast. Und ich finde es total dumm, wenn man die Hände fordert oder sowas, dann die Kopfe rauszunehmen, zu verstauen, sondern ich mache den Transparenzmodus an und kann normal mit den Leuten interagieren. Mir ist aber schon häufig aufgefallen, dass Leute natürlich mich sehen mit Kopfhörer auf und dann vielleicht denken könnten, oh, hört er mich überhaupt, wie unruflich war, man denn nicht raus. Oder checken, dass alle durch die Bank Kopfhörer sind inzwischen transparent oder wenn er keine Musik hört. Das ist ein spannendes Thema, Technik und Höflichkeit, die Wechselwirkung dazwischen. Es gab ja auch eine Phase, wo man komisch angeguckt wurde, wenn man zum Beispiel in der U-Bahn einfach vor sich hin geredet hat. Ohne ein Handy in der Hand oder irgendwie sowas. Und man dachte, was ist mit dem los? Und der hat einfach ein Telefonat geführt über seine Kopfhörer oder irgendwie so. Der technische Vorschritt ist schneller als die gesellschaftlichen Geflogenheiten drumherum. Richtig, aber ich habe das Gefühl, das ist zum Beispiel mittlerweile nicht mehr unhöflich. Wenn du in der U-Bahn stehst und du redest einfach, denkt jeder, okay, ich check die Technologie, der ist nicht weird, der redet nicht mit mir oder irgendwie sowas, ich muss jetzt nicht, sondern man weiss einfach, der redet einfach über ein Headset oder sowas. Ich check die Technik und oder die mentale Krankheit. Richtig. Und hier ist es jetzt an der Kasse, dieser Transparenzmodus ist noch nicht angekommen im Mainstream, im technischen Mainstream. Es gibt noch Leute, die checken das und die checken das nicht. Das heißt, wir sind hier in einer höflichen Grauzone, weil die Person denkt, es funktioniert anders. Das ist ein schwieriger Fall, würde ich sagen, weil ich finde es durchaus unhöflich, Kopfhörer zu tragen. Ich habe ja eher diese Bügelkopfhörer, nicht so diese Stöpselkopfhörer. Aber auch die haben einen Transparency-Mode. Absolut, aber da mache ich an der Kasse immer eine Ohrmuschel ab, eine Ohrmuschel nach hinten. Okay, das ist das, ich gebe dir ein Ohr. Ich finde es, ja okay, gut, müssen wir natürlich von den Leuten, die betroffen sind, direkt hören, aber das ist für mich ein Signal, ich bin offen für Kommunikation, ich bin offen für Rückfragen, halbe Kommunikation, ich bin da. Ich gebe dir das bare minimum. Ja, aber ich finde, es ist schon mal nicht nichts und ich finde, es ist ein Signal, ich nehme dich wahr als Mensch, der eine Stimme hat.
Und als Transparenzmodus ist natürlich eine Frage, da müsste man eigentlich, müsste man das von außen sehen, dass dann so ein grünes Licht ansehen, dass die Person sieht, ah, du bist auf Transparenzmodus.
Weil ich denke natürlich jetzt weiter, angenommen der Transparenzmodus ist angekommen in der Mitte der Gesellschaft, es ist nicht mehr unhöflich, Kopfhörer drin zu haben. Wer sagt denn, dass man dann nicht noch einen Schritt weiter geht und sagt, die Person erwartet, ich mache den Transparenzmodus an, also mache ich den gar nicht mehr an. Ich höre weiter die sogenannte Gegenwart, er vibet da mit irgendwie und die Person und du so, ja, ja, ja, ja, laber du, laber du nur, weil die Person denkt, ich hätte Transparenzmodus drin. Das heißt, hier haben wir ein Problem, weil man sich das in dem unendlichen Kreislauf immer wieder Unsicherheit reinbringen kann, weil Höflichkeit zuerst Sicherheit reinbringen in menschliche Interaktionen, dass wir beide wissen, wir sagen hallo, wir wissen, was zu sagen ist, bitte da. Eine Regel wäre, behandelt alle Kopfhörer tragenden Menschen wie Menschen mit Transparenzmodus, redet normal mit denen. Ich finde es nicht unhöflich, ich finde es auch nicht schlimm, weil das ist auch ein Plastikding, was man im Ohr hat. Ich höre auch ohne Transparenzmodus sehr gut meine Umwelt und ausserdem der Supermarkt. Ich höre teilweise sogar, ich höre besser mit Transparenzmodus, was die Menschen sagen, weil die Stimmen werden sehr klar und das Hintergrundgemummel ist trotzdem nicht so nervig, wie wenn ich einfach gar keine Kopfhörer, so ein Netto bei mir um die Ecke, der ist auch nicht leise, der hat einen Grundrauschen. Ich finde, das wäre okay. Aber da muss man natürlich sagen, Höflichkeit ist ja nicht immer nur logisch, sondern es ist ja auch ein Zeichen. Also wenn du die Kopfe rausstest, zeich. Undichen. Und es ist genauso hinterher, wie die Leute sich über Supermarkt, in der U-Bahn genervt haben, weil Leute für sich geredet haben. Man muss aufholen jetzt. Es gibt den Transparenzmodus, und deswegen finde ich, muss jetzt einfach geupdatet werden. Servicepersonal hat das jetzt als nicht unhöflich anzusehen. Ja, ist schwierig, ist schwierig. Also ich kenne den Transparenzmodus nicht, ich bin da ganz transparent, ich kenne das nicht. Deine Transparenzlamp ist an. Ich habe wirklich nur den, ich höre gar nichts mehr, ich will auch nicht interagieren, weil ich nutze Kopfhörer ganz bewusst auch als Signal. Also ganz wirklich als Signal, wenn du irgendwie unterwegs bist und jemand redet mit dir und du so, okay, Kopfhörer wieder drauf. Also ich nehme eine Muschel ab, Interaktion, alles klar, und ich nehme die Muschel wieder drauf. Unterschied zwischen denen. Klarer Zeit, das Gespräch ist vorbei. Over-Ears sind aber auch heavy. Ja, aber wenn der andere jetzt denkt, Transparenzmodus ist ja egal, dann habe ich eine Höflichkeitsebene weniger, die ich brauche in meinem Leben. Ich brauche Interaktion an und wieder Interaktion aus. Regentese, das funktioniert nicht mit den Airpods. Ich mache die Airpods rein, die Leute würden, glaube ich, nicht so sehr mit mir aufhören zu reden. Diese Geste funktioniert nicht. Ich glaube, weil auch alles, was so mit Zeigefinger und Daumen so funktioniert, hat generell keine grosse Geste. Ja, ist keine coole Geste. Aber dieser riesen Helmartige Wumpf. Ich glaube, der Transparenten-Modus würde besser funktionieren, wenn man ihn von außen sehen würde, wie gesagt. Also jemand kommt auf dich zu und sagt, bist du nicht Stefan Tietze und du drückst an und es ist so Tee, Tee, Tee, Tee, Tee. Vielleicht hört man das auch ganz laut. Aber da habe ich auch ein Problem mit. Oft in der Bahn, dann sitzen da so Jen Sieler, will ich hören, was die reden und wie die reden. Ich will doch nicht, ich will doch nicht den... Dafür hast du einen anderen Knopf. Also du hast zwei Transparenzknöpfe. Du hast den transparenten Transparenzmodus. Hörflichkeitschreif, transparenten Modus. Und du hast den intransparenten Transparenzmodus. Muss ich mir den so unlocken, so bei so einem shady Laden um die Ecke? Ja, der ist ein Abo-Modell, 13 Euro im Monat. Und dann kannst du nämlich Transparenzmodus anmachen und ich will das alles sehen oder ich will es geheim machen. Wir kommen jetzt lustigerweise in eine andere Ecke. Es gibt ja diese Idee, dass Handys, wenn man Foto macht, das zeigen sollen, auch wenn kein Witzlicht ist, damit nicht geheim Fotos gemacht werden können. Nach der Logik muss ja auch, wenn man Transparenzmodus drin hat, das an sein. Ja, ja, ja. Ich möchte gerne Transparenzmodus, ich will auch nicht als Weirdo wahrgenommen werden, wenn ich ... Manchmal habe ich wirklich Transparenzmodus drin, ich höre nichts. Ich finde es einfach viel entspannter. Und dann will ich nicht, dass da so eine Lampe allen zeigt, der hört gerade keine Musik, der hat mal Kopfhörer drin und läuft durch den Flughafen. Was ist mit ihm denn? Ja. Ja, ich finde es nicht leicht, aber vielleicht muss ich selber ein bisschen Erfahrung sammeln mit Transparenzmodus. Denk da mal nach, geh mal in dich. Ich gehe da mal damit schwanger. Das darfst du bitte nicht sagen. Ja, okay. Weil ich habe halt nur meine Klopper. Ich habe halt nur meine Klopper und ich fahre aktuell wieder Fahrrad und ich denke mir, die bieten auch einen gewissen Schutz. Ich muss keinen Helm tragen. Ich bin kein Helmtyp, nie ein Helmtyp gewesen, ich weiß es unvernünftig und so. Obwohl es Statistiken gibt, die besagen, dass man ohne Helm sicherer ist. Was? Weil man anders fährt? Weil das ein Paradoxon und weil du... Das ist leider so ein Paradoxon, da kommen wir nicht raus. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das schlau ist, das zu sagen oder irgendwie, was los ist jetzt. Weil dann manipulierst du die Statistik. Es gibt tatsächlich das Phänomen, zum Beispiel, dass Autofahrer anders fahren, wenn du keinen Helm trägst. Die fahren vorsichtiger, wenn du keinen Helm trägst, als wenn du einen Helm trägst, weil die denken, oh shit, der hat keinen Helm, wenn ich den jetzt umfahre, ist er hinüber und beim Helm da trotzt er halt mal rein.
Das ist so gefährlich, als du gerade machst.
Und jetzt ist es super gefährlich, weil jetzt drehen wir uns halt statistisch im Kreis und das ist alles paradox.
Und weisst du, was das Beste ist, das Umfragenparadoxon, was ich gerade beobachte, wo ich nicht weiß, ob es eine Studie dazu gibt oder so, ohne jetzt zu sehr püchig zu werden, aber ich behaupte, Umfragen lösen gerade die Umfragen aus. Okay. Also du, du, es wird, das ist doch jetzt zum ersten Mal so, seit ich mich erinnern kann und auf der Erde bin und nachdenken kann und die Medien konsumiere und so, ist es jetzt zum ersten Mal so, dass man ständig mit der Sonntagsfrage immer wieder Umfragen, Wahlumfragen, Wahlumfragen. Jeden Tag kriege ich Wahlumfragen, so ist gerade die Wahl. Und das ist total, das ist so weird. Meiner Meinung nach beeinflusst das doch immer, deswegen werden ja die Umfragen auch nicht am Wahltag schon gezeigt, sondern die Hochrechnung gibt es erst am Ende, weil das die Wahl beeinflussen würde. Die Frage jetzt aber, Moment mal, für die Demokratie, muss der Wähler denn wissen, was ungefähr der Stand ist, um vernünftig wählen zu können? Eben nicht. Ich finde eben genau nicht. Das ist nämlich die Frage. Muss der Wähler eine Chance haben, eine Partei wählen zu dürfen, die erfolgreich ist? Was hat denn der Erfolg einer Partei mit der, du sollst ja nicht wählen, welche erfolgreichste ist, sondern du sollst wählen, was du wählen willst? Ja, gute Frage, aber muss der Wähler die Chance haben, strategisch wählen zu dürfen? Ich bin für Umfrageverbot und dann könnt ihr nach der Wahl so 15 Umfragen mal machen, aber bitte auch die Frage richtig stellen. Aber wenn dann einer zu dir kommt und sagt, ey Stefan, ich habe jetzt die Tierpartei gewählt, die ist nicht im Bundestag gekommen, meine Stimme war quasi umsonst, hätte ich das im Vorhinein gewusst, dass die niemand wählt, hätte ich die nicht gewählt. Aber das ist doch generell so ein strategisches Denken, ist ja eh auch weird. Ist das Teil der Demokratie oder nicht? Das ist nämlich die Frage, die ich dir jetzt stelle. Ja, ja, ja, ich möchte es nicht mal verneinen heute, in zwei Wochen sind es wahrscheinlich auch wieder anders. Andersrum kannst du natürlich auch sagen, oh, da gibt es eine Partei, die viele Stimmen kriegt, ich will die bekämpfen, also gehe ich vielleicht erst wählen oder so.
Was für mich nur so krass ist, weil jede Umfrage ist ja eine Frage und jede Frage ist auch immer suggestiv, immer.
Christus kriegt man einfach nicht raus, weil ein krasses Beispiel war, jetzt war ja der Jahrestag vom Kriegsende und sowas und das Jubiläum, 80 Jahre und dann wurde so gefragt, ja, wie finden Sie das eigentlich, dass in Deutschland die ganze Zeit ständig darüber gesprochen wird? Ist es nicht mal langsam zu viel? Fragezeichen? Ja. So, und dann so, und dann haben Sie es auch vorgelesen, in so einem Zeitpodcast auch einfach, ja, erstaunlich, viele Menschen finden die Erinnerungskulturen ein bisschen zu krass. Es wird so oft darüber gesprochen. Und dann, ja, hier wurde nämlich die Frage gestellt, oder reicht es auch langsam mal?
Oder so. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, wenn die Frage, wenn das schon mitschwingt, dass der Fragende da so ein bisschen zu viel von hat, dann glaube ich…
Und die währenddessen streng in die Augen schaut und finden sie nicht auch, dass diese ewige Bombardierung mit Erinnerungen langsam reicht?
Hier auch noch nicht, das verbinde ich so beides ein bisschen, wir hatten ja auch über Handwerker,
da wir zu Hause gesprochen und über Trinkgeld da und das fand ich auch interessant, da haben mir viele gesagt, ja, Münzgeld ist natürlich ein bisschen unschön, aber wenn man das erklärt, ist da niemand sauer und so. Das ist natürlich erst mal komisch und da wird vielleicht auch mal ein Gag drüber gemacht, aber im Kern alle freuen uns darüber. Und ich habe viele Nachrichten bekommen, ich glaube so fünf bis fünfzehn Euro Trinkgeld, je nachdem wie lange die Menschen da bei einem waren, sind schon üblich.
Ach, tatsächlich, Verhandwerker.
Man kriegt sehr gerne was zu essen und trinken angeboten. Essen habe ich noch nie gehört. Die Vorstellung, dass ich dann was so Häppchen mache oder so, finde ich ganz, ganz schlimm. Dann gebe ich lieber mehr Trinkgeld. Aber ja, generell, ja, ich glaube, es tut sich niemandem Abbruch ein bisschen, bricht sich niemanden Zacken an, ausser Corona ein bisschen Trinker zu geben oder Kaffee anzubieten oder was auch immer. Das war auch ein Problem, weil ich habe nie Milch da, weil ich nur schwarz trinke. Und dann sagt er, ich wollte sie einen Kaffee und dann sagt er, ja, mit Milch, ich habe keine Milch, ja, dann nicht. Irgendwann ist es so weit, du kaufst extra Milch, wenn der Handwerker kommt, dann will der keine Milch, dann hast du die Milch rumstehen, dann weisst du nicht, was du da machen sollst. Das ist so ein umfrageartiges Suggestivmoment, weil dann wurde mir jetzt einmal neulich ein Stundenzettel gegeben. Das ist auch übrigens eine veraltete Art, kennst du den Handwerkerstundenzettel? Der Arbeitsnachweis sozusagen. Ach so, und du musst ankreuzen, ja, sie waren so viele Stunden. Ja, du musst unterschreiben. Da schreibt der Handwerker oder Handwerkerin auf, so lange war ich hier, da bin ich gekommen, da bin ich gefahren. Und der Handwerker in dem Fall hat viel zu viele Stunden aufgeschrieben, viel zu viel. Ich habe natürlich unterschrieben mit dem Gedanken, ja, kann ich ja danach dann per Mail oder so sagen, das stimmt ja nicht
oder sowas, wenn es
zum Tragen kommt. Ja. Natürlich kam es
zum Tragen und dann, ja, sie haben den
Stundenzettel unterschrieben, sie haben
den ja unterschrieben, das ist ja ihre Unterschrift,
und dann haben sie mir so eine Mail geschickt, mir unterschrieben.
Ein ganz kindliches Smiley-Unterschrift.
Und ich habe zurückgeschrieben, ja, ja.
Was ich gerne denen sagen wollen würde, ich, ich finde das so gemein, weil ich traue mich nicht, in dem Moment zu sagen, aber sie waren doch gar nicht so lange hier, das stimmt ja nicht. Niemals in meinem ganzen Leben würde ich das machen wollen. Nie im Leben. Ich würde mich niemals entscheiden zu sagen, das stimmt nicht, das unterschreibe ich nicht. Wie gemein ist das denn? Aber ich finde es trotzdem auch nicht cool. Nee, das ist furchtbar. Kann man da nicht … Also ja gut, Datenschutz und so, aber kann man nicht irgendwie … Und dann die Frage, was hat denn der Handwerker davon? Er wird doch wahrscheinlich vom Betrieb fix bezahlt.
Er hat doch nichts davon, wenn er oder ist es provisionmäßig? Ja, oder er kann halt, wenn er sagt, ja, ich war bis 18 Uhr hier und er war nur bis 15 Uhr hier, geht er noch drei Stunden in den Europapark oder so. Ja, so gehen Leute in den Europapark, mal eben nach dem Arbeitsplatz. Dann nach zehn, sei er drei Stunden, ich gehe noch drei Stunden auf die Kugel.
Das war der Punkt, wo alle gemerkt haben, die beiden haben jeglichen Anschluss zur Realität verloren.
Ja, was machen Handwerker nach Feierabend? Die gehen ja irgendwie schon in die Ackerbahn.
Auch Europa-Park oder keine Ahnung, Wasser-Wunderland.
Nee, aber kann man da nicht irgendwie so mit so GPS arbeiten, dass der so einen Chip hat und dann kann man sehen, wie lang war der an wel welchem Ort, aber gut, du sagst Datenschutz und Menschenrechte und blablabla. Du bist heute radikal, du willst blinkende Transparenz. Ich bin heute radikal, ich will mal voran, ja, ich will mal ein bisschen vorankommen in der Gesellschaft, dass wir wirklich hier auch Hürden genommen werden, einfach von mir aus. Ich meine, ich habe nichts zu verlieren. Meine Stimme wiegt sehr wenig in der öffentlichen Meinung der Gesellschaft, deswegen von mir aus kann ich auch mal was sagen, was nicht stimmt.
Und dann gibt es auch dieses Beispiel, die Frage Statistiken bedingen die Realität, bedingen Statistiken, bedingen die Realität, wie unser Helmbeispiel gerade. Piloten, da gibt es nämlich bei Anfängern, bei Fluganfängern gibt es die Death Zone.
Und zwar ist das genau die Zeit, wo eine Anzahl an Flugstunden, die man hat, in der die meisten Unfälle passieren, weil man sich zu sicher wird. Und es ist wirklich einfach ein Einfall, Sicherheits, wie man sich das vorstellen, ist einfach so ein Knick im Graphen, und das ist sozusagen die Sicherheit, die abnimmt. Weil Leute in diesem Bereich, dieser Flugstunden auf der x-Achse, zu, ja, Ungenauigkeit oder fehlender Konzentration oder sowas leiden. Also zum ersten Mal nimmt man so Freunde mit, um das mal zu zeigen. Ja, ja, man fliegt mit verbundenen Augen, sowas halt. Also Quatsch halt. Und das finde ich so interessant. Da muss dann erst mal was passieren, bis man sagt, oh shit, okay, das ist ernst, ich mach's wieder. Warum steigt es wieder an? Weil dann nach gewissen Flugstunden dann so eine Professionalität oder so eine Routine einsetzt, was auch immer. Oder dann irgendwann ist man, vielleicht auch bei den Ungenauigkeiten sind die so in Automatismen übergegangen, weiss ich nicht, dass man das überspielt,, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde es spannend, deswegen, und es wird massiv über diese Death-Saison gesprochen, so massiv, dass die verschwindet. Kann ich mir vorstellen, ich weiß nicht, aber die wird verschwinden. Ach so. Weil die wird gelehrt jetzt an Flugschulen, da es diese Statistik gibt. Und dadurch macht man sich natürlich jetzt, wenn man in diesem Bereich ist, sehr viele Gedanken. Ich dachte, es wird schlimmer, weil du so Nachrichten kriegst von deiner Flug-App, Achtung, sie sind in der Death Zone, Death Zone, Death Zone, sie fliegen heute in der Death Zone. Und du so, okay, alles klar, jetzt fliege ich mein Flugzeug und man hat die ganze Zeit Death, Death, Death im Kopf. Man hat so Panik, dass man dummen Fehler macht.
Genau, und dann macht man natürlich einen dummen Fehler, dann fliegst du falsch rum oder irgendwie sowas,
oder auf den falschen Landeplatz oder irgendwie sowas, das geht ganz schnell.
Ja, Streisand-Effekt.
Auch, ja, es gibt verschiedene Effekte, die uns beeinflussen, links und rechts, an jeder Ecke, du wirst überall durch die Gegend geschubst.
Zum Glück ist es für uns nicht so relevant. Es gibt den Streisand-Effekt und den Papageno-Effekt, und die widersprechen sich beides. Es sind beides medienwissenschaftliche Begriffe. Der eine sagt aus, man macht das, worüber in den Medien gesprochen wird. Ist ja auch so eine Suizidberichterstattung zum Beispiel, ist immer so die Frage, soll man das machen oder nicht, weil es kann präventiv wirken und kann aber auch zum Suizid führen. Und das ist super interessant, weil das ist ja genau, was du gerade meintest, der Helm, wozu führt, was du, wenn du darüber sprichst. Es gibt aber auch den Bauerneffekt, der besagt, dass es zu jeder Regel auch die gleiche Gegenregel gibt. Weil es gibt zu jeder Bauernregel auch eine Bauernregel, die genau richtig wie der Schuss. Jetzt müsste man rücken, weil das Gegenteil ist von Bauern. Springer. König eigentlich dann so in der... Ja, die Königsregel. Genau, dass man sagt quasi immer so, im April ist immer Wechselwetter und dann gibt es auch eine Regel, die sagt, im April ist immer Regen oder irgendwie sowas so und dann widerspricht sich das genau und es gibt für alles so eine Weisheit irgendwie und das ist auch so. Am Ende null spricht alles. Am Ende kürzt sich alles raus. Am Ende ist alles egal. Am Ende kürzt sich alles raus und es ist komplett bei null. Materie, Antimaterie, Pasti, Antipasti, am Ende sind wir bei Null. Ja. Am Ende sind wir bei Null und wir lösen uns langsam auf.
Das ist doch das Ende des Universums.
Wenn alle Probleme gelöst sind, alles sich rauskürzt. Ich glaube, irgendwann gab es mal so eine Erfindung oder sowas wie Materie.
Oh, okay, dann gibt es Antimaterie.
Und dann, das ist wirklich mein Blob, meine Blob-Theorie.
Ja.
Es gab eine Ungleichheit, weiss ich, habe ich publiziert, wurde verrissen, aber ich höre nicht auf. Geolino hast du die veröffentlicht? Ich habe das schon seit Längerem, eine Geolino-Glosse. Mir ist erst einmal was eingefallen, deswegen habe ich es noch nicht so oft da publiziert. Aber das war bahnbrechend, das war der Blob-Effekt. Der Blob-Effekt, die Blob-Theorie. Okay, die nochmal blautet, es bloppt irgendwas und ... Naja, das Universum ist ein grosser Blob. Ja. Also es gab ja davor keine Zeit, keine Naturwissenschaft, keine Gesetze, nichts. Ja. Also ist es wie ... Wenn keine Zeit ... Hallo, das ist Infinite ... Wenn Worte nicht mehr reichen, um die Theorie zu beschreiten. Damit du schnippst. Du bist so weit, dass die Worte dir ausgeht. Naja, es ist ja das Infinite-Monkey-Theorem. Wenn es unendlich viele Affen an Schreibmaschinen gibt, wird einer davon die gesammelten Werke von Shakes beschreiben. Weil es gibt ja keine Zeit. In der Unendlichkeit gibt es ja keine Zeit. Unendlichkeit ist Unendlichkeit. Und wenn es keine Zeit gibt und es nichts gibt, in dem Nichts, nichts ist ja auch unendlich, gibt es dann irgendwann, gab es sowas wie Pasti und dann gibt es Antipas. Und dann, sobald es etwas gibt, ist null ist nicht alles, sobald es etwas gibt, gibt es etwas anderes. Und das ist sozusagen so ein Blob, der aufgegangen ist, und darin sind wir gerade, wir befinden uns in der Mitte des Blobs. In der Mitte? Also wir haben noch ein bisschen. Oder am Anfang oder am Ende, ist völlig egal für den Blob. Der Blob ist ganz kurz, aber in der Unendlichkeit des Riesenuniversums ist der recht lang für uns. Okay. Und irgendwann löst sich alles auf und der Blob macht sich wieder zu. Das ist natürlich ärgerlich, wenn der Affe komplett alle Shakespeare-Stücke perfekt schreibt.
Und am Ende sind Schreibfehler.
Und am Ende einfach nur mal so Romeo und Juliop.
Und so, oh nee, bis dahin war alles richtig.
Sorry, wie kann man hier, wie kann man löschen?
Bis dahin war alles richtig.
Ach, fuck.
Die Inendlichkeit ist gruselig.
Aber die Affen schreiben ja auch alle zukünftigen Werke, also alles, was es jemals geben wird. Also du könntest quasi auch zu dem Affen gehen und sagen, gib mal den neuen Romanen von Benjamin von Stukradbarra oder so, der noch nicht veröffentlicht ist. Ja, genau. Weil die schreiben ja alles, was überhaupt... So schreibt Benjamin von Stukradbarra seine Romane, weil er klaut mir die Sachen, die ich geschrieben hätte. Ja, und eigentlich auch jede Musik und jeder Film, jedes Drehbuch. Du könntest eigentlich, anstatt ein eigenes Drehbuch zu schreiben, könntest du dir unendlich viele Affen holen und sagen, der nächste Nolan-Film ist ja auch schon dabei. Ich weiss dir immer was Spannendes bei der Unendlichkeit, wenn ich unendlich viele Affen beschäftige, bei mir im Hinterhof, in Ehrenfeld Finde ich ja nicht denjenigen, der das … Die Chance ist unendlich klein.
Du brauchst unendlich lange, um den nächsten Nolan-Film zu finden.
Und das geht mir ja die ganze Zeit schon so.
Du könntest aber auch Glück haben und einfach so der erste Affe so, was ist das fünf, acht, äh, Müll, was ist das Chambowambo, egal, Müll, der dritte, oh wow, das ist der James-Bond-Film, den Christopher Nolan gerade schreibt. Hier ist er schon fertig, super. Nächste Zeitung ist die Zeit der Zeit, die die Zeit der Zeit, die die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, die Zeit, Müll der dritte, oh wow, das ist der James-Bond-Film, den Christopher Nolan gerade schreibt.
Hier ist er schon fertig, super, ihr könnt alle gehen, ihr könnt alle gehen, ihr könnt alle gehen und dann die Reisebusse.
Da will ich nicht in Köln Auto fahren, wenn unendlich, Klammer auf Ausrufezeichen, Klammer zu, Affen nach Hause müssen. Ja, und wo wohnen die alle? Verkehrsgaros. Nee, in dem Hotel, in Hilberts Hotel. Ja, und das ist ja irgendwo am Dom, ne, da in der Gegend. Und da müssen die da alle hin. Ach, nervig. Eine Folge für unsere, ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja, für Mathefriks, warum denn nicht? Ja, warum denn nicht? Ja, ich wüsste ein paar Gründe, warum nicht. Ja, gut. Wir sind noch nicht bei Folge unendlich angekommen. Wir haben noch einiges vor uns. Fühlt sich aber so an. Okay. Alles klar. Nee, Flontien, es macht jede Woche wieder aufs neue Spaß. Bin ich ehrlich. Wir sind, glaube ich, immer noch in der Service-Ecke. Wollen wir die kurz zumachen? Ach so, ja. Zuerst, danke. Aber bevor wir ganz kurz, bevor wir die Service-Ecke zumachen. Danke, dass du zu Gast warst, Stefan, dass du heute mal dabei bist. Ich bin mal dabei. Ist es doch irgendwas, was du irgendwie plagen willst, woran du gerade arbeitest oder so, willst du, dass die Leute hören? Das kann ich ja gleich im Podcast dann sagen, hoffentlich, weil ich bin ja... Wir machen das immer so hier hier in der Serviceecke, dass wenn jemand zu Gast ist, hat der auch
die Möglichkeit, was zu sagen, so eigene
Projekte oder so, schreibst du gerade einen Film oder
irgendwie, oder? Kann ich ja den Podcast dann
davon erzählen?
Ey, du musst nicht so bescheiden sein, du kannst hier gerne auch für deine
Website oder so, hast du eine Website oder einen
Social Media Auftritt oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich mag dieses Rubrik auch dann nicht.
Okay, gut, dann. Florentins ServiceEcke. Ecke, Ecke, Ecke, Ecke. Wow, tolle Service-Ecke. Vielen Dank dafür und vielleicht sehen wir uns nächstes Mal wieder. Das war's schon für diese heutige Folge. Wenn ihr uns sehen wollt, aus irgendwelchen weirden, weirder Fuck-up-Gründen, dann könnt ihr das tun, indem ihr uns auf Patreon abonniert,
patreon.com slash das Podcast-Ufo, da gibt es alle Folgen auch als Video.
Werbefrei.
Werbefrei, ihr kriegt zehn Prozent auf Merch.
Geil.
Und da können wir auch mal das Merch-Projekt angehen,
mit dem, ich habe online Trinkgeld gegeben, T-Shirt.
T-Shirt, ja, bitte fragt, bitte schauen mir nicht in die Augen.
Finde ich sehr lustig, wenn wir das mal nachgehen.
Vielen, vielen Dank an euch da draußen fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank an dich, Florentin, fürs Dabeisein.
Danke, danke, danke, vielen Dank an Schermatize, dass er zu Gast war in der Serviceecke.
Vielen Dank auch an unser phantastisches Intro, das diese Woche kam von Marco.
Vielen, vielen Dank, Marco.
Haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, tschüss, schau mich wie Bob! So where is purple ice cream? Wir und Gäste wie Anja Rützel, Wanni schreibt, Jan Köppen oder Bachelor Nico Griesert schauen mit, lachen mit und leiden natürlich auch mit. Während andere dich für dein Guilty Pleasure Trash-TV schief anschauen, sagen wir seit mittlerweile fünf Jahren Willkommen zu Hause. Und jetzt kommt's, auch in diesem Jahr sind wir wieder auf Tour durch ganz Deutschland und Österreich. Also, wenn du dich gerade angesprochen fühlst, checke gerne Erdbeerkäse-Podcast.de für die Termine und Tickets. Guter Geschenktipp übrigens für alle Trash-TV-Fans im Freundeskreis oder halt die, die es endlich mal werden sollten. Wir kriegen sie alle. Also Erdbeerkäse, der Trash-TV-Podcast, überall wo es Podcasts gibt und dieses Jahr übrigens auch auf grosser Tour, bestimmt auch in deiner Nähe. Erdbeerkäse-Podcast.de.